[Esta charla contiene contenido maduro. Se recomienda discreción del espectador]
Mi especialidad, como educadora sexual, es dar paso a la ciencia.
Pero mi primer tarea y más importante es mantenerme neutral
cuando hablo de cualquier cosa relacionada con el sexo,
sin vergüenza, sin excitación, sin juicio, sin vergüenza,
no importa donde estoy.
No importa la pregunta que me hagan.
Al final de una conferencia en el lobby de un hotel,
literalmente yo saliendo por la puerta y una colega me persigue.
"Emily, solo tengo una pregunta muy rápida.
Una amiga mía...
(Risas)
quiere saber si es posible volverse adicta a su vibrador".
La respuesta es no, pero es posible arruinarse.
Una conferencia diferente, en un paraíso tropical al aire libre,
estoy en el buffet de desayuno y una pareja se me acerca.
"Hola, Emily, lamentamos interrumpirte
pero solo queríamos hacer una pregunta rápida sobre la eyaculación precoz".
"Claro, déjenme contarles sobre la técnica de parar e iniciar".
Esa es mi vida.
Me mantengo neutral cuando otras personas sienten "pudor".
El pudor es una emoción que combina sorpresa
con vergüenza y algo de disgusto
sin saber uno qué hacer con las manos.
Así que es producto de algo.
La razón por la que lo experimentamos
es porque pasamos las primeras dos décadas de la vida
aprendiendo que el sexo es una fuente peligrosa y repugnante de vergüenza eterna
y si no somos realmente buenos en eso, nadie nunca nos amará.
(Risas)
Así que si sienten pudor, escuchándome hablar sobre sexo
mientras están sentado en una sala llena de extraños, eso es normal.
Les invito a respirar.
Los sentimientos son túneles.
Nos abrimos camino a través de la oscuridad para llegar a la luz.
Y prometo que vale la pena.
Porque quiero compartir con Uds. hoy una parte de la ciencia
que ha cambiado la forma en que pienso sobre todo,
desde el comportamiento de los neurotransmisores
en nuestro cerebro emocional,
a la dinámica de nuestras relaciones interpersonales
en nuestro sistema judicial
Y comienza con nuestro cerebro.
Hay un área de tu cerebro que probablemente han escuchado
y se llama "centro de recompensa".
Creo que llamarlo centro de recompensa
es un poco como llamar a tu cara, nariz.
Esa es una característica prominente,
pero ignora otras partes y nos dejará realmente confundidos
si tratamos de entender cómo funcionan las caras.
En realidad, se trata de tres sistemas entrelazados pero separables.
El primer sistema es el de gustar.
Que es como recompensa,
ese es el punto de acceso opiáceo en tu cerebro emocional.
Evalúa el impacto hedónico.
"¿Este estímulo nos hace sentir bien?
¿Cómo de bien?
¿Este estímulo nos hace sentir mal?
¿Cómo de mal?"
Si ponemos agua azucarada en la lengua de un recién nacido,
el sistema de simpatía por opioides activa fuegos artificiales.
Y luego está el sistema volitivo.
El deseo está mediado por esta vasta red dopaminérgica
dentro y más allá del cerebro emocional.
Nos motiva a acercarnos o alejarnos de un estímulo.
Querer es más como tu niño pequeño, que te sigue,
pidiendo otra galleta.
Así que querer y gustar están relacionados.
Estos no son idénticos.
Y el tercer sistema es el cognitivo el de aprendizaje.
Aprender es lo de los perros de Pavlov.
¿Recuerdan a Pavlov?
Él hacía que los perros salivaran en respuesta a una campana.
Es fácil, das comida a un perro, saliva automáticamente,
y suena una campana.
Comida, salivación, campana.
Comida, campana, salivación.
Campana, salivación.
¿Esa salivación significa que el perro quiere comer la campana?
¿Significa que el perro encuentra la campana deliciosa?
No.
Lo que Pavlov hizo relacionar la campana con la comida.
Cuando vemos esta separación de querer, gustar y aprender,
aquí es donde encontramos un marco explicativo
para entender lo que los investigadores denominan
excitación no deseada o sin concordancia.
Sin concordancia es cuando hay una falta de relación predictiva
entre su respuesta fisiológica, como la salivación,
y su experiencia subjetiva de placer y deseo.
Eso sucede en todos los sistemas emocionales y de motivación que tenemos,
incluido el sexo.
Investigación en los últimos 30 años
ha visto que el flujo sanguíneo genital puede aumentar
en respuesta a estímulos relacionados con el sexo
incluso si esos estímulos relacionados con el sexo no están asociados
con la experiencia subjetiva de querer y gustar.
De hecho, la relación predictiva
entre la respuesta genital y la experiencia subjetiva
está entre el 10 y 50 %,
lo que es un margen enorme.
Simplemente no se puede predecir necesariamente
cómo se siente una persona con respecto a ese estímulo relacionado con el sexo
solo analizando su flujo sanguíneo genital.
Cuando le expliqué esto a mi esposo, él me dio el mejor ejemplo posible.
Él dijo:
"Eso podría explicar que una vez, estando en la escuela secundaria,
tuve una erección en respuesta a la frase 'agujero de rosquilla' ".
(Risas)
¿Quería tener sexo con la rosquilla?
No.
Era un adolescente inundado de testosterona,
lo que hace que todo esté un poco relacionado con el sexo.
Y puede ir en ambas direcciones.
Una persona con pene puede tener problemas de erección una noche,
y luego despertar a la mañana siguiente con una erección,
cuando no es más que una molestia.
Recibí una llamada telefónica de un amiga de 30 años
y me ella dijo, "Mi novio y yo estábamos en medio haciendo cosas
y le dije: 'Te deseo dentro ahora en este momento'.
Y él dijo: 'No, todavía estás seca, solo quieres ser amable'.
Y yo me sentía muy preparada.
Y entonces ¿cuál es el problema? ¿Es hormonal? ¿Debo hablar con un médico?
¿que esta pasando?"
¿Cuál es la respuesta?
Es excitación sin concordancia.
Si experimentan dolor no deseado, hablen con un médico.
Si no se trata de excitación sin concordancia.
El comportamiento genital simplemente no necesariamente predice
nuestra experiencia subjetiva de querer y desear.
Otra amiga en la universidad
me contó de sus experiencias de juego de poder en una relación sexual.
Ella me dijo que su compañero la ató
los brazos sobre su cabeza así, ella estaba de pie y
él la sentó a horcajadas sobre un taburete
que le presionaba el clítoris, así.
Ahí estaba mi amiga, así ahí y entonces el tipo se fue.
Es un juego de poder.
La deja sola.
Y mi amiga dice:
"Estoy aburrida."
(Risas)
Y el tipo regresa y ella repite: "Estoy aburrida".
Y él la mira y mira el taburete
y él dice: "Entonces ¿por qué estás mojada?"
¿Por qué estaba mojada?
¿Está relacionado con que el clítoris tenía presión directa?
Sí.
¿Eso muestra si ella quiere o le gusta lo que está sucediendo?
Nop.
¿Dice eso si ella quiere o a le gusta lo que está pasando?
¡Sí, ella lo dice!
Ella reconoció y articuló lo que quería y le gustaba.
Todo lo que tenía que hacer él era escuchar sus palabras.
Mi amiga en el teléfono preguntó cuál era la solución.
y yo: "Le dices a tu compañero que te escuche".
Y compra un poco de lubricante.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Aplausos para el lubricante, por su puesto.
Todos, en todas partes.
Pero quiero contarles una historia más oscura.
Surge de una nota que me envió una estudiante
después de dar yo una conferencia sobre excitación sin concordancia.
Ella estaba con una nueva pareja
feliz de estar haciendo cosas y llegaron a un punto
donde ella no quería ir más lejos
y entonces ella dijo que basta.
Y el compañero dijo: "No. Estás mojada, estás muy a punto, no seas tímida".
¿Tímida?
Como si no le hubiera tomado todo el coraje y la confianza que tenía
para decirle basta a alguien que le gustaba y
cuyos sentimientos ella no quería lastimar.
Pero ella lo dijo de nuevo.
Ella dijo que ya basta.
¿Escuchó sus palabras?
En la era de Me Too y Time's Up, la gente me pregunta:
"¿Cómo puedo saber lo que mi pareja quiere y le gusta?
¿Todo el consentimiento es verbal y contractual ahora?
Hay momentos en que el consentimiento es ambiguo
y necesitamos una conversación cultural a gran escala sobre eso.
Pero, ¿podemos asegurarnos de que notamos cuán claro es el consentimiento
si eliminamos este mito?
En cada ejemplo que he descrito hasta ahora,
una de ellas reconoció y expresó lo que quería y le gustaba:
"Te deseo dentro ahora en este momento."
"Basta."
Y su compañeros les dijeron que estaban equivocadas.
Es hacer luz de gas.
Profundo y degradante.
Dices que te sientes de una manera,
pero tu cuerpo prueba que sientes otra cosa.
Y solo hacemos esto en torno a la sexualidad,
porque la excitación sin concordancia
sucede con cada sistema emocional y motivacional que tenemos.
Si salivo cuando muerdo una manzana podrida,
¿alguien puede decir:
"Dijiste que no, pero tu cuerpo dijo que sí"?
(Risas)
Y no solo nuestras parejas se equivocan.
El Programa Nacional de Educación Judicial publicó un documento
llamado "Lo que los jueces desearían saber antes de presidir un juicio
de una víctima adulta de agresión sexual ".
En el número 13 se lee:
En ocasiones, la víctima, mujer u hombre, puede experimentar una respuesta física,
pero esta no es una respuesta sexual en el sentido de deseo o mutualidad".
Esto me lleva un paso más hacia la oscuridad,
y luego prometo que encontraremos nuestro camino hacia la luz.
Pienso en un caso judicial reciente que involucra varias instancias
de contacto sexual no consentido.
Imaginen que están en el jurado
y saben que la víctima tenía orgasmos.
¿Cambia la forma en que su instinto responde al caso?
Déjenme recordarles que el orgasmo es fisiológico;
es una liberación de tensión espontánea e involuntaria
generado en respuesta a estímulos relacionados con el sexo.
El abogado del perpetrador se aseguró de que el jurado supiera de esos orgasmos
porque pensó que los orgasmos podrían interpretarse como consentimiento.
Agregaré que la víctima era un niño abusado por un adulto en la familia.
Les invito a respirar.
Ese tipo de historia confiere a una persona todo tipo de sentimientos,
de la rabia a la vergüenza a la excitación confusa
porque está relacionado con el sexo,
a pesar de que es atroz.
Pero a pesar de que sé que es difícil
bregar con esos sentimientos en una sala llena de extraños,
si encontramos nuestro camino a través de todos los sentimientos confusos,
creo que encontraremos nuestro camino de la luz de la compasión
para ese niño,
cuya relación con su cuerpo estaba dañada
por un adulto cuyo trabajo era protegerlo.
Y tendremos la esperanza de que haya un adulto en el que confiar
quién pueda decir: "La respuesta genital
solo significa que fue un estímulo relacionado con el sexo;
no significa que fue querido o deseado,
ciertamente no significa que fuera consentido.
(Aplausos)
Esa compasión y esa esperanza es la razón para viajar yo por todas partes,
hablando de esto a cualquiera que quiera escuchar.
Así es cómo ayudo a la gente, incluso mientras digo algunas palabras.
Les invito a decir esas palabras.
No tienen que decir "clítoris" ante 1000 desconocidos.
Pero tengan una conversación valiente.
Cuéntenle a alguien que conozcan quién ha experimentado violencia sexual.
seguro conocen a alguien.
En EE. UU. es una de cada tres mujeres.
Uno de cada seis hombres.
Casi la mitad de las personas transgénero.
Digan: "La respuesta genital significa que es un estímulo relacionado con el sexo.
No significa que fuese querido o deseado".
Díganselo a un juez o a un abogado que conozcan o un policía
o a cualquier persona susceptible a sentarse en un jurado
en un caso de agresión sexual.
Por ejemplo, "Algunas personas piensan que su cuerpo no responde bien
si no quieren o no desean lo que está pasando,
si solo eso fuera cierto.
Eso es excitación sin concordancia.
Digan esto al adolescente confundido en su vida
quién está tratando de descubrir algo.
Digamos, si muerdes esta fruta mohecida y salivas,
nadie te dirá:
"Simplemente no quieres admitir cuánto te gusta".
Lo mismo vale para la excitación sexual sin concordancia.
Díganselo a su pareja.
Mis genitales no dicen lo que quiero o me gusta.
Lo decido yo.
(Aplausos)
Las raíces de este mito son profundas
y están enredadas en fuerzas muy oscuras en nuestra cultura.
Pero con cada valiente conversación,
hacemos que el mundo sea un poquito mejor, un poco más simple
para el adolescente confundido.
Algo más fácil para tu amigo al teléfono preocupado de que ella esté mal.
Un poco más fácil y seguro
para los supervivientes de agresiones sexuales.
Una de cada tres mujeres. Uno de cada seis hombres.
La mitad de las personas trans.
Yo también.
Y por cada conversación valiente que tengan,
gracias.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Helen Walters: Emily, ven aquí.
Muchas gracias.
Sé que haces esto todo el tiempo,
y sin embargo, aún así, estoy muy agradecida por tener el coraje
de venir y hablar de eso en este escenario.
Realmente costó mucho y te estamos muy agradecidos.
Así que gracias.
Emily Nagoski: Estoy agradecida de estar aquí.
HW: En tu trabajo diario normal,
como dices en tu charla,
te hacen muchas preguntas.
Pero ¿cuál es la pregunta que te hacen todo el tiempo
que puedes compartir con todos aquí para no tener que responderla mil veces
durante el resto de la semana?
ES: La pregunta que me hacen con mayor frecuencia
es en realidad la que me plantean después de otras preguntas
como si una puede hacerse adicta a su vibrador.
O si puedo ayudar con su disfunción eréctil.
Después de cada cuestión me preguntan: "¿Soy normal?"
A lo que mi respuesta en mi mente es:
"¿Qué es normal y por qué es eso lo que quieres que sea tu sexualidad?
¿Por qué solo queremos ser normales en torno a la sexualidad?
¿No queremos ser extraordinarios?
¿Te gusta el sexo normal o quieres sexo increíble en tu vida?"
Creo que, sin embargo, hay mucho miedo
de ser demasiado diferente sexualmente.
Cuando me preguntan,
"¿Es normal esto que estoy experimentando?"
Lo que en realidad me pregunta es: "¿encajo?"
¿Encajo en esta relación?
¿Encajo en esta comunidad de personas?
¿Pertenezco a la tierra como persona sexual?
A lo que la respuesta es siempre un rotundo sí.
La única barrera que hay, los únicos límites que hay son dos:
uno, si experimentas dolor sexual no deseado,
habla con un médico.
Y dos: siempre y cuando todos los implicados sean libres
y contentos de estar allí, y libres de irse cuando quieran,
puedes hacer lo que quieras.
No hay guión, no hay lugar donde encajar
está permitido, siempre que haya consentimiento y no haya dolor no deseado,
uno es totalmente libre de hacer lo que quiera.
HW: Increíble. Muchas gracias.
ES: Gracias.
HW: Gracias, eres increíble.
(Aplausos)